alors on bonjour autour de la planète
bienvenue à tan tan canada qui vous
elle de nouveau studio numéro 93 celui
là
c'est à travers 92 plus du avant celui
ci et c'est notre deuxième année
seulement ici uniquement comme ça en
diffusion directe non seulement
aujourd'hui sur facebook la grève mais
sur youtube
alors si vous ne l'aimez pas obtenu en
facebook vous allez sur youtube nous
voir et la semaine prochaine on espère
pouvoir vous années comme ça en direct
sur la page d'un radio canada
international
la première page vous verrez comme ça
dans deux secondes l'émission va
commencer il rend un décompte je ne sais
pas si on a des comptes comme sur
envoyer une navette spatiale mode quoi
nous c'est promis au monde il aa 11h11
on n'a plus le choix c'est un ordinateur
qui décide de l'heure du moment de la
minute la seconde de notre départ
aujourd'hui en studio qui est avec nous
et bien sûr nos meilleurs amis on a
invité nos meilleurs amis pour ce
nouveau lancement d'émissions tentant
canada hameury bonjour bonjour stéphane
on l'applaudît marque montgomery qui est
avec nous du service anglais de radio
canada international
marie claude simard notre webmestre du
côté français c'est notre chef de du ils
ont l'air de rien avec leur appareil
mais c'est mixte ou essentielles sur
cinq ans et un ongle et puis évidemment
les eaux gimeno qui épouse est prêté
pour toujours par la sélection espagnole
et on est l'unique émissions et à cinq
émissions retransmises par en cinq
langues par radio canada international
onu l'unique mission qui a besoin de
deux webmestre pour assurer la diffusion
trop complet des fois eric c'est vrai
pas seulement des fois trois fois au
moins
parce que l'autre était malade ou
l'autre s'est absenté marie claude a
tout fait
fantasque fait pas de jaloux en effet
avec l'air un peu endormi au jour non
non je suis concentré alors aujourd'hui
l'émission c'est le titre trucs et
attrapes pour honfleur est insomniaque
alors oui gillison en sus des yeux c'est
la preuve que je suis un ronfleur non
insomniaque
je vous posais la question vous
complétez je suis un peu comme si motif
oui mais je suis psychiatre ma question
est très subtil jeu 6/4 d'accord vous
adresser à - ou répondait à vous
complétez cette phrase voilà pour moi
mal dormir c'est
ben c'est que mon petit hamster il
n'arrête pas de tourner dans ma tête
quand je me couche le soir et donc ils
m'empêchent de dormir mais je ne ronfle
pas n'a pas de conjoint est donc elle
rappelé ma fille me dit maman tu ne
ronfle pas et votre fille elle ronfle
non plus non plus à cette famille
j'imaginais mal à marquer mango marie
compléter la phrase donc pour moi mal
dormir c'est parfois difficile et
apparemment j'avais entendu des autres
personnes disent que oui je suis un
ronfleur je voudrais pas il ya personne
dans votre vie autrement de 6 des fois
dix fois
des fois j'ai aussi une choc et
l'anglais c'est je ne sais pas
marie-claude pour moi mal dormir c'est
l'enfer sur terre
oui peut-être pas juste une soirée mais
plusieurs jours deux fils louis c'est
vraiment l'enfer et puis vous voulez
aucun jeu normal je me rappelle de mes
rêves j'adore profondément alors j'aime
c'est la seule façon de me rappeler mais
le reste c'est certainement la question
est-ce que son est ce qu'on s'en
souvienne de nos rêves
bonne question c'est pas le sujet de ces
démissions ce sera la semaine prochaine
dont voici les premières questions
remuez vous les méninges cette semaine
un donc après le test du psychiatre
aussi la fabrication le vrai test de la
semaine sur 100 canadiens selon vous aux
canadiennes en ce moment combien
souffrent d'insomnie ce sera le premier
sujet dont on m'a traitée aujourd'hui
les ronflements c'est pour la deuxième
portion l'émission donc insomnies 100
canadien combien on souffre en ce moment
quand 50 juste pour différencier 60 60 %
des canadiens 60 canadien sur 100 sauf
actuellement d'insomnie mais qu'est ce
que tu entends paraît sominice que c'est
juste une soirée et une nuit aussi à la
définition les chercher
il ya l'insomnie chronique salle pour
condom ont soudain puis allez souvenu ce
n'est soumis à l'occasion moi je vous
parle ici de ce qu'ils ont en ce moment
en ce moment c'est à dire beau temps
mauvais temps
en ce moment 5 65% roula et 0,42
calonne de celui qui est la bonne
réponse le plus proche de la fin de
réponse est personne qui a la bonne
réponse de tous très éloignées 10% de la
population
oui seulement mais attendez là à
demander la question combien
d'annonceurs voilà alors mais en fait il
ya un adulte sur trois qui vivrait de
l'insomnie à l'occasion ça c'est des
statistiques tirées d'un sondage
effectué par statistique canada il y a
de cela
2011 donc ça dingue peut-être les choses
et ont un peu évolué à l'occasion que
diriez vous si on allait poser des
questions aux spécialistes soutenait les
plus récents à l'offre recherche là
dessus voici notre invité en direct de
montréal donc pas quelques pas d'ici
mélanie vendette bonjour madame van deth
alors vous êtes neuropsychologue donc
pas psychiatre donc c'est moins grave de
vous parler c'est moins dangereux et
vous travaillez dans un au centre
d'etudes avancées en médecine du sommeil
de l'hôpital du sacré coeur de montréal
est là en faisant des recherches me suis
aperçu que il ya plusieurs endroits au
canada où on fait de la recherche sur
les problèmes du sommeil c'est un gros
problème apparemment c'est comme vous le
mentionnez la problématique d'insomnie
c'est le problème de ce mets qui est le
plus fréquent en criant dans la
population et il ya plusieurs centres
d'études de sommeil à travers le monde à
travers le canada
puis nous au centre d'etudes avancées en
médecine du sommeil
on est également une clinique de sommeil
donc non seulement on fait des études
sur le sommeil mais également des
investigations diagnostic et le
traitement des troubles du sommeil ce
qui nous différencie un autre centre de
semaine à travers le monde
donc vous mettez des fils après la tête
des gens qui souffrent d'insomnie et
voulu suivi durant toute la nuit est ce
que c'est ça non prenez c'est ma fête
s'apprend pas absolument une
investigation de sommeil pour avoir un
diagnostic d'insomnie comme vous l'avez
mentionné tout le monde
un peu donné sa définition de ce que
c'était une nuit difficile donc simple
insatisfaction par rapport à son sommeil
on peut souffrir d'insomnie
en autant que ça allait des
répercussions sur notre fonctionne tous
les jours on sait pas nécessaire de
passer un test diagnostique à l'hôpital
ou dans un centre d'étude de sommeil
dans une clinique de sommeil mais
effectivement qu'on va faire d'ailleurs
pour éliminer le ronflement illuminé
l'apnée du sommeil ou d'autres problèmes
de sommeil oui alors je vous dirais qu
ici à tous il ya tous les individus
autour de la table après presque tous
ont des problèmes de de rendement au
travail
notez ça et on soupçonne ici l'insomnie
mais réellement sérieusement c'est un
problème sérieux là qu'il faut
absolument traité dans combien dans
combien de cas comment est-ce que c'est
souvent que ça se produit ou quoi
écoutez quand vos statistiques était
vraiment excellente
c'est vrai que un peu plus même que 30%
de la population qui vont des
insatisfactions rapport à leurs sommets
des répercussions ou du moins à plus
court terme
yoyo 10% de la population shakeel
problèmes d'insomnie vont persister et
va devenir chronique
donc c'est ce 10% là de la population
qui est traité le vraiment
spécifiquement dans l'eau dans notre
clinique
alors j'ai des deux patients ici est-ce
que vous avez des questions pour la
psychiatre la psychiatrie golog est ce
que vous les traitez est ce qu'ils n'en
guérit c'est ce qu'ils finissent par
retrouver le sommeil nous la méthode
qu'on utilise sacré car c'est une
approche dite cognitive comportementale
de l'insomnie donc c'est sa médication
en plus et puis c'est vraiment une
approche c'est un traitement qui savent
à hyper efficace qui ont été démontrés
scientifiquement avec un taux
d'efficacité de 70 à 80% comportementale
ça veut dire que il ya unan une attitude
dans l'équipe qui est à décommander est
donc vraiment dans l'insomnie quand le
problème il ya pratiquement toujours des
aspects psychologiques et des aspects
comportementaux qui rentrent en jeu
dans le maintien du problème de sommeil
alors on traite avec une approche
cognitive comportementale les aspects
qui sont plus de psychologiquement
également comportementaux donc toute
sorte d'habitude qu'on peut être amené à
prendre qui vient d'être finalement
sommeil alors qu'on pense bien faire
donc c'est on doit on doit aider les
gens à pouvoir prendre de bonnes
habitudes
bon moi ça ce n est pas qu est ce qu est
ce qu est ce que je dois changer pour
essayé de m'endormir le soir je vous
donnais un truc moi ce que je fais ça
fonctionne pas toujours parce que l'idée
me trotte dans la tête souvent je pense
aux patrons je pense aux patrons je
prends du patron jean finit plus alors
mais qu'est-ce que je laisse venir les
couleurs les formes la lumière je laisse
aller ma tête autrement dit à accepter
ce qui est ce qui vient de dents je
remplace les idées par des formes et ça
marche presque à coup sûr je m'aperçois
même pas je me sens a dormi c'est mon
truc mais ça fonctionne pas tout le
temps la suisse quand même pas un truc
parce que c'est une forme de deux
méthodes de relaxation qui est propre à
vous il y en a toute sa technique de
relaxation effectivement d'ajustement
les approches pour traiter l'insomnie
c'est sûr qu'on va utiliser une
technique de relaxation point est forte
la technique si on a eu une note
on sent bien avec eux on peut l'utiliser
tout à fait vous disiez plutôt que iapps
et pas seulement un problème de
comportement aussi mais un problème de
psychologie doudou le fait que vous êtes
une psychologue au départ spécialiste
des neurones 12% des insomniaques sont
insatisfaits ou très insatisfaits de
leur vie au canada conquête % chez ceux
qui dorment sur leurs deux oreilles
j'ai tiré cette information d'un
compétiteur de radio-canada le fait de
souffrir d'insomnie mais je voudrais que
sur le plan psychologique il ya toutes
sortes de facteurs qui rentrent en jeu
dans le le maintien du problème
d'insomnie en trop du taux de croyance à
la base des croyances qui sont tout à
fait réalistes à part au sommeil entre
autres la croyance qu'on absolument de 8
heures deux semaines pour bien
fonctionner mais ça souvent
mais c'est une croyance qu'on a pu chez
certaines personnes c'est pas possible
de pouvoir l'atteindre
donc c'est une personne qui oppose cette
physiologie là d'avoir un huit heures de
sommeil qui va essayer de tout faire de
faire attention de pouvoir avoir une
heure ça va nuire des insatisfactions ça
rentre en jeu dans le problème de sony
écoutez on a seulement huit heures
d'émission donc il va vous falloir le
voulait laisser aller mais écoutez
c'était fantastique de savoir qu'il y
avait des gens qui ne ferme pas les yeux
sur ce qui se passe est jamais joué
vraiment d'un terminal pour vous mettre
dormir c'est quoi exactement je sais pas
si ça vous arrive la remarque m arrive à
tout le monde
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà réveillés
parce que vous rend fier ok ça arrive
des fois on se fait réveiller papa par
soi même
écoutez merci beaucoup madame van deth
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pied
levé nous avons partagé la science une
partie de la science canadienne à ce
sujet là merci beaucoup trop oui c'était
trop bon c'est sûr mais là seulement
huit heures d'émission comment on va
faire pour écouter ici au studio je vais
vous demander
j'ai trouvé une autre méthode
apparemment le new york times s'y
intéresser oprah winfrey la future
présidente américaine
si c'est du sérieux c'est dur et sans
même que radio canada international un
sas et le tampon officiel ça veut dire
que ça fonctionne a fait un article là
dessus au sujet d'un canadien qui
s'appelle luc beaudoin professeur
adjoint à la faculté d'éducation et
nuances termine fraser en
colombie-britannique dont qu'à l'autre
bout du pays
vous ne savez pas contacté pas besoin
t'as pas besoin parce que je les
écoutais et puis les plus tôt en dormant
mais non je fais des farces je pense que
je vais dire qu'il dormait si vous
voulez y aller mais l'entrevue qui est
fait récemment par radio canada
international lui on a mis ça sur notre
page web de tam-tam canada quand je dis
que c'est pas nécessaire c'est qu'on a
au moins les images oui ça a l'air
d'être numéro 1 et numéro 2 0 2
toutefois pas qu'on va présenter la
numéro 1 c'est normal on manque de
sommeil
on y va alors ça c'est donc le résultat
de la requête de monsieur luc beaudoin
il a créé une application qui s'appelle
en anglais c'est ce liban ou en français
bâton bouton dodo et ça permet de vous
endormez plus rapidement son truc c'est
que l'application vous mais défend
tendre et vous montrent aussi les images
de certains articles ou objet et vous
demande de les visualiser
pendant que vous essayez de vous
endormir alors là on l'entend en anglais
qui s'expriment qui parle de ça de son
invention il faut encore garder un outil
entre les mains
regarder des objets voilà c'est un peu
contradictoire tout à fait
contradictoires surtout c'est un écran
bleu ce téléphone qui vous donne accès
l'autre solution et il en parle
voyez lui le monsieur n'a pas
l'application donc ça va mal se passer
pour lui il va passer toute la nuit
debout et à réfléchir à plein de choses
même compté dix moutons et le que dit
que ça ne sert à rien compter du mouton
enfin ça ça pas grand chose sa méthode
est plus efficace si vous n'avez pas
l'application vous pouvez vous même la
recréer dans votre tête mais un peu
d'effort et donc vous pensez à un objet
oublier l'application là vous pensez à
un objet comme avion et vous c'est vous
visualisez l'avion est ensuite vous
devez thierry chacune des lettres du mot
avions comme a comme auto imaginez une
auto ensuite
v comme véhicule imaginer un véhicule
comme ea com inde
enfin vous voyez à l'infini j'ai essayé
ça cette semaine ça a marché
je suis devenu extrêmement nerveux j'ai
souffert on se marche pas on va montrer
ça ici à la caméra slip battles à
islington pensez vous que cette caméra
peut capter l'essentiel de la science
c'est trop loin
en tout cas c'est un beau un gribouillis
ça fonctionne pour vous oui c'est je me
donne jusqu'à 200 moutons c'est à 200 ch
pas endormi je me lève je fais d'autres
choses mais sinon la chanteuse française
carla bruni sur un de ses albums à la
fin la dernière chanson
ça c'est elle est un mouton de fini par
s'endormir
alors soit les jetables sexistes et puis
on va visualiser quelque chose vidéo de
0,1
on vient en arrière dans notre machine à
remonter le temps et voici une image à
marie elle a la réponse j'en suis sûr
mais qui est on va demander à marc qui
est cet homme qui s'est endormi devant
ses collègues de travail à montréal il
ya deux ans je me rappelle dans quelles
entreprises il travaillait il venait
juste de commencer en plus il était
nouveau dans l'entreprise
parce qu'ils étaient un peu fatigués ce
matin là il s'est endormi puis
évidemment tout le monde s'est foutu de
sa tronche là ils ont bien rigolé
marcussen et non pas du tout pourtant
c'était ça a provoqué un arrêt
planétaire autour de la planète est bien
évident succès planétaire c'est très bon
s'est endormi premier jour de travail
dans une compagnie d'informatique et ses
collègues ont pas pu s'empêcher de
prendre des vidéos de lui enfin le livre
des images et un étudiant d'une hostie
concordia qui était donc aux études au
travail s'ils étaient un peu épuisé il
s'endormait comme ça ça c'est le
contraire de l'insomnie 7 s'endormir
spontanément voilà c'est au total
je me souviens d'avoir vu des images
dans le journal journal des policiers
qui sont endormis dans l'eure dans leur
auto les employés de radio-canada
mais vous savez c'est tellement pas
évident aussi maintenant les gens
travaillent bon déjà sur différents
horaires c'est travailler jour/nuit soir
et les vies sont folles entre ce qu'on
fait à la maison ce qu'on fait au
travail ça n'arrête pas je sais pas je
suis bien d'avoir travaillé les chiffres
de nuit et c'était l'enfer je ne suis
pas capable
c'est de travailler la nuit ça c'est sûr
le travail de nuit
moi je les fait un été et puis j'ai pas
survécu mais des gens pour qui ça
convient très bien
il préfère saipem celle de la boj
interne
alors voici notre deuxième question ruby
ménages qui vaut pour 30% dans notre
finale ou des vraies
première question c'est est un pur sang
et je vous rappelle que leonardo est le
grand vainqueur de la première manche 2e
manche
quel pourcentage des adultes canadiens
devront rendre environ
ils devront prendre from brome la nuit à
des degrés variables front pis il range
combien tel pourcentage des adultes
canadiens vrombissent la nuit à des
degrés variables 80 80 c'est
décourageant non moi je dis que 30 pour
cent quarante bon alors vous en parle à
qui aurait mal pris l'habitude en plein
milieu alors tous les deux remporté 30%
ça vient ça va bien alors 20 % à 30 % 30
% vous comprenez pourquoi je ne partage
pas une histoire à raconter
jeune je ne j'avais un accident de moto
assez grave
merci donc j'ai passé quelques semaines
dans l'hôpital et je me souviens que il
y a des gens qui font gonfler cette
incroyable j'ai jamais entendue car
j'étais dans une aile de l'hôpital dans
l'autre aile je les ai entendus comme
ddt locomotive c'était incroyable c'est
pas possible de ronfler si fort que ce
site est un complément
- j'ai déjà je me suis réveillée par mon
propre rôle en moi mais de la place
c'est pas intéressant dans le train
quand j'aurai bien la maison
[Rires]
c'est effectivement pas très beau mais
enfin ça c'est mon chat attend de voir
qu'est ce que je vais vous proposer la
question tu entames écoute cette semaine
mais il salue ses nouveaux studios dont
qui nous mentent les banderoles de radio
canada international il nous manque la
télévision bon endroit pour que vous
puissiez voir tout en parlant au micro
donc je vous demande de faire deux
choses en même temps dans deux
directions impose opposé on va demander
à moi qu eux
voici la question chien oui voici la
question
les ronflements des hutus votre propre
sang qu'est-ce que vous garde le plus
fin
on va demander un français de répéter la
question c'était pour le bénéfice de
tous parce qu des mois la phase i vous
êtes endormir la maison laisse bizet les
questions oui alors donc les ronflements
des autres ou votre propre à sony
qu'est-ce qui vous garde le plus souvent
éveillé la nuit et que faites vous pour
y mettre fin
réponse d'une auditrice françoise
depardieu dans le sud de la france
depardieu bonjour les amis cette
question me touchent au quotidien
comme vous le savez je dois partager mon
logis avec trois gros nounours
soit mais deux gros garçon est mon mari
donc le bruit la nuit
j'en suis une experte experte du
camouflage des oreilles plus mon mari a
pris du poids au fil des ans plus il a
additionné les décibels
mes fils au moins sont dans une chambre
séparée par des toilettes et des
placards mon truc et de m'endormir avant
les autres sinon je suis bonne pour
l'insomnie
je fais des moitiés de nuit depuis au
moins dix ans mon mari me dit sans
délicatesse que je ronfle aussi comme un
canard alors je sens que je n'ai pas le
droit à la critique
j'aimerais être seul dans mon lit faire
chambres séparées mais je ne suis pas la
reine de mon foyer et certainement pas
la reine d'angleterre qui elle a les
moyens de s'offrir ce luxe
c'est peut-être la raison de sa
longévité mon mari me raccourci la vie
c'est triste mais à vrai dire je ne
vivrai pas longtemps sans lui c'est le
sort de millions de couples dans le
monde je crois belle histoire d'amour
autour du ronflement n'est ce pas pour
ce qui est des choses a des choses à
endurer de ceux de ces conjoints yama
des moyens de guérir le ronflement mais
c'est un petit coup de coude d'un
général art est non
moi ça moche objet utilisé une une je
sais pas une pelle ça fonctionne puis
encore fini mais je fais plus rien moi
je vois si comme le dernier cri bonne
question qu'est ce qu'on peut faire un
power régler amplement le dernier cri
pour faire taire les ronfleurs canadien
d'abord c'est de les amener chez le
médecin les convaincre d'y aller c'est
un problème sérieux pourtant il ya voici
la vidéo numéro 4 qui vous présentent
ils vous offrent c'est un bug au canada
maintenant à ce moment c'est de plus en
plus populaire ça s'appelle la
ventilation spontanée en pression
positive continue alors vous vous
remettez ça vous mettez ça sur la tête
c'est comme s'ils vont tomber avec alors
ça consiste à souffler de l'air
pressurisé à travers un masque et on
veut ici en empêcher l'affaissement des
voix inspiratoire c'est la première
option en ce moment de traitement aux
canards dans la fesse notre couple avec
ça ou sinon celui qui dort à côté de
cette machine
j'adore l'expression anglaise c'est
l'expo l'abri sur anglaise pour ça ça
s'appelle six pack ou autrement dit en
français crap est relié à un compresseur
donc ça fait du bruit
c'est une histoire de bruit moins
brillant que le ronflement j'imagine
alors voilà voyez comme comment on sent
une fois qu'on a passé à travers le
traitement reçu également une maman qui
tente de convaincre son mari d'utiliser
le sait pape de d'aller voir le médecin
en lui apportant donc un échantillon à
la maison et idia qu'est ce que tu veux
que je fasse avec ça c'est bon donc
c'est mon imagination encore une fois
faut pas rentrer dans la chambre à
coucher des canadiens quand même mais on
va y rester
c'est un plaisir n'est-ce pas de ferme
voici l'autre technique
anne-marie vous savez poser les bonnes
questions quoi faire ça c'est là peu de
vidéos numéro 5 nous offre l'autre
affaire moins chers et très en vogue
notamment chez les dentistes qui le
proposent ça s'appelle ben c'est pas les
dentistes qui propose ça ne s'appelle la
prothèse la prothèse voit la prothèse
dentaire et le collège des médecins est
pas content
parce que les dentistes et les
entomologistes voilà vent de certaines
ces appareils là mais lorsque c'est mal
ajusté
ça peut créer une déformation du palais
et dédain alors essentiellement ça
permet de garder ouvert la bouche la
nuit pour que le passage de l'air si
effectué saint saëns grand deux sens
entre absents mais c'est bien fait et
disent très scientifique m'ont dit que
avant de vous mettre dans la bouche de
vous laisser convaincre il faudrait
quand même aller chez le dentiste le
vrai danseuse professionnelle pour qu'il
évalue si c'est adapté à votre dentition
si ça va pas causer d'autres problèmes
apparemment ça cause des problèmes des
déplacements de mâchoires la nuit et
finalement on règle un problème pour en
créer un autre on reparlait des gens qui
n'ont pas assez qu'ils prennent du poids
c'est vrai c'est sérieux c'est ce que
révèlent les études depuis à peu près
quatre ou cinq ans maintenant il ya
plusieurs études qui le confirme si vous
dormez moins que vous 7h 5h seulement
votre masse corporelle et 3,5 pour cent
plus élevés selon une enquête récente
que j'ai consultés c'est normal on est
éveillé plus longtemps donc on a
tendance à manger plus souvent non je
sais pas est ce qu'il ya un lien
bah je sais qu'on mange plus oui on
mange plus on salive plus pour les
aliments sucrés par exemple les gras on
est éveillé en attendant j'ai par un kid
ordinn mais là c'est sûr que qui ne dort
pas dean ont cherché une satisfaction et
on l'obtient voici une grosse bête qui
grande satisfaction qui passent beaucoup
de temps à dormir un peu trop de temps
apparemment c'est notre vidéo numéro 6
et notre vidéo virale de la semaine
présenté par tam tam canada notre
sélection à passer au vote
et voici ce que ça donne c'est l'ourse
qui monte au poteau pour piquer un
sommeil sas et passe en saskatchewan et
les allaient réparer la ligne d
électricité en saskatchewan ils ont eu
la surprise de voir ça ils ont pris des
images lourd s'était perchée tout à fait
en rond il dormait environ 150 km au
nord de la grande île de saskatoon ils
ont cherché un moyen des employés de
ramener notre brave animal sur la terre
ferme sans blessés et causé une panne
électrique aussi mais lui il a fini par
redescend à l'équilibré
oui je voulais vous parler des ours
parce que vous savez que c'est très
canadien comme sujet et aussi les ours
passe passant beaucoup de temps à dormir
peut-être qu'ils ont des trucs que l'on
pourrait adopter comme ne jamais sortir
de notre tanière l'hiver ça pourrait
être la peur de questions revenir mais
vous les ménages c'est bon pour 50%
d'examen donc vous pourriez remporter
aujourd'hui vous avez 0 % 30 % 30 % 20 %
vous pourriez de la grande gagnante on
est prêt alors voici un nom ce noir au
canada hibernent l'hiver pendant combien
de mois en moyenne
un ours noir au canada hibernent hiver
pendant combien de mois en moyenne 12 à
2 peu là l'hiver dure trois mois alors
je vais dire trois mois voulait que je
complète la question oui sinon un plus
de 3 mois non plus de deux mois plus de
quatre mois plus de six mois aux aucune
de ces réponses le l'ours noir au canada
hibernent l'hiver pendant combien de
mois
il ya plus de deux mois plus de deux
mois aucune de ces réponses dans ce sens
qu'il ya des climats qui changent
partout au pays donc quelques places
peut-être plus longtemps que d'autres
dans le nord du colombier choix ne sont
pas partout les ours noirs 1 ben oui
moyenne fait qu'ils sont au canada aux
états unis jusqu'au mexique savoir j'ai
appris ça sont pas si nombreux qu'on le
pense chansons autour de 20 mille ou des
reins au mexique c'est un peu compliqué
mais en tout cas
ouais c'est vrai que sont peut-être un
peu un peu plus besoin c'est
marie-claude + 2 - plus de quatre mois
plus de quatre mois
la bonne réponse aucune de ces réponses
d'accord mais pas pour la bonne raison
que racisme question trouvez ça arrive
des fois le professeur il le radar mais
l'ours noir n'hibernent pas au sens
strict du mot parce qu'ils passent
l'hiver dans une table seulement de
somnolence pour hiberner il faut
vraiment descendre sa température
ralentir le rythme de son coeur à un
niveau de quelques battements par minute
seulement ce que peut faire certaines
espèces certaines petites espèces mais
pas les autres
donc ils n'hibernent pas mais ils hiver
voilà la leçon français cette semaine
cette le deuxième tir sogeti côté
français mais faut pas écouter ce qu'on
a mangé quelque chose pour vous j'ai
juste eu un petit cadeau à la fin
d'émission un petit mot un petit dessert
parce que vous êtes à espace autochtone
oui et on a retrouvé un reportage qui
était fait il ya olala 2013 ou alors que
radio canada international était une
nouvelle aventure du web
oui à vous souvenez bien sûr là
aujourd'hui on est à l'époque de
facebook et youtube mais à cette époque
là on était on essaie d'apprendre ce que
c'était de faire des pages web et de
mettre des articles sur et adrien lachat
oui je travaille aujourd'hui pour nhk
c'est au japon au japon allait faire une
entrevue avec un homme qui était
responsable d'une connaissance il ya un
nom en anglais en anglais s'élancera
donc une maison blanche et il avait fait
c'est en trouvez que c'est un musée qui
se trouve dans la région de québec qui
offre aux citoyens
oui racontez-nous le reste ben là je
sais pas je n'ai pas écouté son
reportage mais je la connais la maison
gawane d'acteurs match connaît l'ouest
de wendake et oui on voit montrer les
images là j'y suis allé plusieurs fois
pour le plaisir parce que c'est vraiment
un bel endroit puis je ne sais pas si on
a un extrait de cette entrevue lable oui
on écoute puis on qui a posé par dessus
des corps pour traditionnellement
maintenir les écoles en place et éviter
qu'elle ne parte ou va ton fils ton
voile dans un premier temps et qu'est ce
qu'on voit à l'intérieur d'enfants
comment on vivait là l'époque comment
vous avez reproduit ça comme il y avait
des personnes qui vivent elles comment
la manière de calculer le nombre de
personnes qu'on retrouve dans une maison
langues
c'est en comptant le nombre de foyers à
l'intérieur de la maison qu'on retrouve
au sol donc ce qu'on sait c'est que
traditionnellement un foyer accommode
douze familles dont 10 femmes et ils
sont disposés çà
la face dans la maison donc quand on
rentre à l'intérieur de la maison une
grande allée centrale dans cette allée
l'on retrouve certains nombres de feu et
ses feux loi bon mon servira d'éclairage
au chauffage à la cuisson également des
aliments à l'intérieur de la maison et
les deux faits les deux familles se font
ça trois piètres du même foyer est dans
notre maison il ya trop feu donc de
chaque feuille bon pour deux familles ce
qui nous conduit à sa famille x 5 égale
trente personnes environ pour ce type de
bâtiment
c'est sûr que si on compare ça que nos
standards modernes
si demain je suis jeune et que je
voudrais probablement surtout quand la
l'hiver mais ces gens là étaient quand
même un sursis au foie alors voilà ça se
passe dans comme on disait oui ça c'est
à wendake et mais en fait il ya un site
comme ça énorme en banlieue de montréal
ça s'appelle le site joggeuse
et c'est vraiment formidable à visiter
c'est une demi heure de montréal dans le
sud on a fait beaucoup de recherches
archéologiques d'ailleurs sur ce site là
on a découvert beaucoup beaucoup
d'artefacts vraiment intéressant et
c'est ouvert au public évidemment pour
la visite et tout est le site et est
vraiment immense ya plusieurs maisons
longue plein plein de choses à voir et à
faire en cas on a le choix si vous mes
proches de québec sont indiquées où il
faut aller à luanda qu'il ya un hôtel
musée là bas qui est formidable
il ya des chutes incroyable et chute
kabir kouba là non je vous le dis c'est
un lieu à découvrir avec une communauté
formidable alors voilà pour la note de
l'examen qu'est-ce que marquer 0-0 pense
à moi j'étais à quand j'étais à l'école
j'avais des zéros sur 20 en
mathématiques à la suite de ça
n'arrêtait pas non plus gros c'est pas
si grave survivre et voici pour vous au
bout et 80 mais je ne mérite pas parce
que j'ai pas vraiment les bonnes
réponses le poids l'âge
j'accepte les 70 vous avez été chanceux
donc pourquoi
merci beaucoup je vais préciser que donc
il ya cinq émissions le vendredi
maintenant de radio canada international
en 50 différentes qui sont diffusées en
direct
présentement c'est le seul qui est
française avant nous c'était nos amis de
la section chinoise
ça n'augure pas bien pour votre pote
diffusion en direct à quelle heure vous
êtes en direct aujourd'hui en anglais
13h13 même studio c'est cela donc vous
pouvez rester nous on va les manger non
au rejet de travail à faire besoin bon
ben c'est tout je vais j'avais quelque
chose à vous suggérer pour terminer un
exercice un peu d'éducation physique
vous permettez d'accord bon on vous
regarde faire les je vais pas faire ça
en début d'émission qui sera peur des
conséquences désastreuses
mais voici nous allons tous payet sait
que le bâillement communique d'animaux
en animaux et d'êtres humains animaux
assez s'éteint comme réflexe quelque
chose qui est honnête on a déjà fini des
amis puis avait un ami qu'on voulait pas
la voir qui on a commencé à bâiller puis
loterie a dit ok c'est musculaire
c'est en voyant j'ai appris à mettre ma
main devant la bouche devant quand je
baille
ma mère m'a toujours dit j'ai pas le
goût de voir tes ennemis dalle elle a
tout à fait raison
en fait le bâillement j'ai apprécié
cette semaine ya plein de choses que
j'ai vraiment très peur à cette
démission par des choses en fait est que
le bâillement est contagieux oui et ça
ne force pas les gens à s'endormir en
fait c'est un message on dit alerte
allait réveiller ou le salaire ennuyeux
le professeur il est en lien tout est en
ligne
l'animateur je dois pas les faits et
puis réveillez vous c'est il faut il
faut il faut gagner l'énergie pour
garder le bas donc bonne chance contre
moi c'est ma règle aucune preuve
ouais c'est ça la semaine prochaine je
serai bien policier alors d'autres
conséquences à l'émission non la semaine
prochaine au sujet des a suivi déjà
sujet j'ai déjà joué
merci quoi passer que la faisant un rush
20 à 10 un indice
ça aura quelque chose à voir avec les
femmes les autochtones les personnes de
couleur différente de la majorité
d'orientation sexuelle différente deux
planètes différentes faut rajouter ça
c'est long c'est une langue qu'elle se
passe quand on a besoin de 8 heures à
couvrir tout ça c'est des ovnis quoi
mais j'aimerais ça mon âge j'ai fait
l'émission sur les ovnis et puis on a eu
des patrons devant envoyé des
[Rires]